there was a moment from last night's
debate that went viral everybody's
talking about it
it was Donald Trump's very awkward
attempt to high-five fellow nominee ben
Carson people today are describing it as
the worst high-five in history let's
take a look President Bush did he not go
to war okay so I just like that let's
see that again slow down let's just take
a look at that again yeah well here's
something here's something a lot of
people don't know that was not a
spontaneous gesture by Trump Trump has
been practicing that high-five for weeks
it was the only preparation he did for
the debate apparently he used a
top-of-the-line world-renowned high-five
coach he's here we have Trump's
high-five coach on the show tonight
please welcome from the high-five
Academy in Thousand Oaks coach Mike
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is one of those go please go
[Applause]
one guy in the audience he just put his
hands all over his incredible alright
and and it was free yeah person didn't
pay for that wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]